Herkese merhaba geldim değil mi
bağlandım bağlı bu sefer oldu Helal
Ettim nasılsın İyiyim ben de
heyecanlıyım biraz Açıkçası ben daha çok
yapabilirim Hatta sana Evet şimdi ben
yavaş yavaş konuya da girişim bu
bitmiyor Çünkü sana verdiğim için sadece
liseye giriş sınavı değil üniversite
sınavı değil okuldaki ders sınavlarımız
değil veya arasındaki bir başvuruda bir
sınav yaptığım bir seminer bir konuşmacı
olmakta bir sınav en basitinden bir
ehliyet sınavı dır hepsi bir sınav yani
çünkü sen bir performans sergilemeye
çalışıyoruz bir başarı göstermeye
çalışıyorsun ve bu başarıdaki göstermeye
çalışır
Bu forma Simya ilgili bir kaygı
duyduğumuz zaman bu sınav kaygısı oluyor
Neler yaşıyorsun Sınav kaygısı Sınav
kaygısı kendimiz yapıyoruz Bizim
kendimize ait olan bir kaygı O yüzden
dedim ki sebep sınavı çözüm benim Çünkü
çözüm yine biziz kendimi biz bu bize
ayrılan dışarıdan gelmiyor Ve bunu
çözülmeye biliriz bazen başka bir fiyat
rahatsızlıklarla beraber olabiliyor
ekleri durumlar olabiliyor öyle bir
durumda ruh sağlığı uzmanları çocuk
Ergen ve yetişkin Ayrıca
değerlendiriyoruz baktığımız zaman ne
hissediyoruz sınav esnasında çok geniş
duymak duyma çok boşluğa düşme kalbini
çarpması Başaramayacağım yapamayacağım
rezil olacağım gibi düşüncelerin olması
düşüncelerle beraber gerçekten de göster
için farklı olmaz daha ayıp olmasın
performansını gerçekten bunlara bağlı
kalbi yönelik düşmesine bir sınav
baktığımız zaman nedir Yani olumsuz ve
olumsuz sonuçlara yönelik ortaya
çıkabilecek olan durumlarda yer olumsuz
olumsuz ortaya çıkabilecek bir duruma
dair bir düşüncemiz oluşuyor ve bir
performans Kaygımız oluşuyor ve
gerçekten de performans saygısında
yöneliktir performansınızı başımıza
düşürmüş oluyorsunuz Sınav kaygısı anne
ama bunu bileşenleri var düşünce
bileşenleri zihinsel bileşenleri var
duygusal bileşenleri var fiziksel
dediğimiz bedensel hissettiğimiz
davranışsal bileşenler şimdi tedavi
ekolleri farklı farklı bakıldığı Zaman
Makinesi düşünceden davranışı gidiyor
kimse duygu düşünce ve davranış şekilde
davran
bu Türkiye düşünceye gidenler vardı
farklı yönler değiştirebiliyor Ama asıl
altta yakasını baktığımız zaman bu
düşüncemiz bizim sınava yönelik
kendimize ait özelliklerin söylüyor
Benim kendime ait olan olumsuz düşüncem
buna benim diyorum Çünkü de düşüncem
diyorum Çünkü neden bu benim düşüncem bu
düşüncenin gerçekleşme ihtimali düşük ve
benim her düşüncem gerçekleşme
gerçekleşti ben çok sevdiğim böyle bir
çok yere Böylece bunu düşün her şey
gerçek yapabilirdim bu benim düşüncem ve
bu düşüncenin de farklı bileşenleri
varsa başarısızlık korkusu ve ilgili
bileşenleri olur Çaresizlik hissi ile
ilgili bileşenleri var veya kendime
kattığım değer ile ilgili olan
bileşenleri vardır Kısaca bahsedeceğim
bazı bunlardan çünkü Eğer siz nerede
yaşıyorsunuz Bizler de yaşadı hala bazen
yaşıyoruz
10 bahsetmek istiyorum biraz teorik
bilgi gibi gelecek ama ben de bu var
demek ki bundan mış Evet ben bunu bu
şekilde engelleyebilirim fikrine sahip
olasınız diye sen beni durdurup
sorabilirsin beyaz isteyenler da al
alttan yazabilirler Şimdi mesela
Çaresizlik hissi dedim kendilik değeri
ile ilgili ve başarısızlık korkusu ile
ilgili düşünceler var dedim bunlar nasıl
oluşuyor çaresiz ikisi dediğimiz durum
da mesela ben bir sınavda başarısızlık
yaşıyorum ama bunu başarısızlığın var
kendimi Naz çalışmasına değildi dış
faktörlere bağlıyorum işte diyorum ki
Öğretmen bana taktı işte diyorum ki şey
Dışarıda çok gürültü vardı o yüzden
yapamadım diyorum ki işte sorular zordu
o yüzden yapımı hani çok ısmarlıyorum
ama bilmiyorum
oy oy saani Aslında ben hazırlan
almamışım drama tamamen sebebi kendime
değil başkasında arıyorum dur dış
ortamda veya başka bir kişi de böyle bir
durumda Ben kendimle ilgili sorunu
göremediğim zaman sadece bu dünya
yazdığın zaman diyorum ki Ben ne
yaparsam yapayım bu olmayacak Ben bu
olumsuz çarptı bir kurbanım yani kurban
gibi hissediyorum kendimi çaresiz
hissediyorum Ne yapayım başarısız olur
olmazmış gibi hissediyorum Oysa bu
benimle ilgili bir dur ben yeterli uçup
gitti çalışmayı göstermiş zormuş olmaz
ama sebebi kendim de aramam dışında
dünyaya vururum böyle bir çok çaresiz
kurban gibi hissedebilirim ikinci mesela
bahsedeceğim kendilik değeri ile ilgili
şimdi bu bizde en sık olan şeylerden
birisi Aslında notları puanlar Çünkü
ders notları vardır ve
ben gelirim Yani ben 90 aldıysam
başarılıyım dır iyiyimdir 70 aldıysan
başarısızdır Yani ben kendimi aldığım
notlar ve aldım puanla derecelendirilir
Semi puanlarda kendimi kıymetli değerli
görürüm düşük puanlar değilse kendimi
değersiz diyorum beceriksiz başarısız
olduk Neden benim Sadece notlara
bağlarım kendini bir bütün olarak
veremem beni ben yapan şey çünkü annem
beni ben yapan insan ki notlar mış gibi
değerlendirdim işte 70 aldığımda a****
olarak değerlendirebilirim 100 aldım da
o çok iyi gibi değerlendirebilirim Oysa
ben kimim ben Ecenur değil mi beni ben
yapan şey başka bir sürü kimliğim var
yani Öğrenci kimliğim var çocuk kim var
arkadaşım var dış ortamdaki sosyal
birçok kimliğim notlar
çok acı hayatımın bir parçası ama ben
notlara göre kendimi dereceler bilirsem
bu sefer kendimle ilgili değersiz
hissetmeye başladım diğer bir durumda
başarısızlık korkusu bununla 7.30
yaşıyoruz çevrenin beklentileri
karşılayamayacağı mızda ilgili İşte
öğretmenlerim benim için çok emek verdi
annem babam benim için çok emek verdi
Eğer başarısız olursam onların yüzüne
nasıl bakarım utanılacak bir durum bu
duyarım esnaf gibi ani Sınav sonucunu
yaşam sonucu uyumuş gibi bağlayan
durumlarda başarısız yaşıyoruz Biz ama
sonucu benim yaşamla ilgili insanların
beni değerlendireceği durumla ilgiliymiş
gibi bir başarısızlık hissediyoruz Yani
bu üç temel bileşen Aslında baktığımız
zaman sınav kaygısının zihinsel ve
bilişsel belirtilerinizi insan
belirtilerini korku yapıyor
Evet şimdi bunları nasıl
değiştirebileceğimiz ile ilgili ben en
son sizle mesela Biraz böyle şey
örnekler yapacağım ki size farklı olsun
diye çünkü bu konuşmada Evet ben size
bilgi vereyim Siz ne yaşıyorsunuz diye
hem de İşinize yarar birkaç teknik
geleyim şurasında bir hafta kaldı ne
kadar bayram o kadar sevinirim Çünkü
bunları anlatıyorum ben şimdi biz de
söyle durum oluyor kişi birçok Bize
başvuran kişilerde olabiliyor hangi
durumu yaşarsa Yaşasın sadece kendi
yaşadığı için veya çevresinden bunun
duymadığı zaman sanki kendi yaşıyormuş
bir tek bu yaşıyormuş başka kimse
yaşamıyormuş gibi hissediyor ve kendini
yalnız ve öteki leşmiş hissediyor Oysa
şöyle söyleyeyim Herkes yaşıyorum az
veya çok herkes yaşıyor yanınızdaki
arkadaşınızla yaşıyor komşumuz da
yaşıyoruz elinizde yaşıyor abinin
ablanız
Bu kardeşimiz de yaşayacağız Yani bu
durumları yaşayanlar Siz tek siz
değilsiniz özellikle bilgi veriyorum ki
A bu bende var Bak ben de böyle
hissediyorum yaşayın bilim bunun normal
olduğunu anlayın diye bu bilgileri O
yüzden veriyorum çünkü hepimiz yaşıyoruz
Biz Uzmanlar olarak da bunu her gün
görüyoruz biliyoruz yalnız değilsiniz
Öncelikle onu söyleyim tek eşya
değilsiniz şu sınav kaygısını diğer
fizyolojik yani bedensel belirtileri ne
geldiğiniz zaman ne yaşıyor çarpıntısı
kalbi yerinden çıkacakmış gibi bir
çarpıntı nefes darlığı titreme terleme
Ellerimi ayaklarımı buz gibi kesilmesi
bazen bayılmalar bulantı hissi kusma
ishal bunun gibi belirtiler yaşıyorsunuz
Bunlar Tabi ki de ortaya çıktığı zaman
kişinin performansında düşürebilecek
şeyler gerçek Aslında ve esnasında ishal
yaşamak Ellerim demesi işte üşümek
titremek bunlar
bu iş sizin olumsuz düşüncelerinizin
olumsuz düşüncelerimizi ikincil olarak
çıktı gibi çıktıktan sonra da olumsuz
düşüncelerimizi dikiş tren şeyler A bak
kalbimde çarptı kesin yapamayacağım ben
bu sınavdan geçemeyeceğim gibi bu sefer
olumsuz düşünceniz iyice tetikleniyor
Aynen öyle Eyvah yapamayacağım bak
ellerimde Cidde'de eşim de geldi şimdi
tuvalete de gidemeyeceğim karnım
gurulduyor galiba ishal olacağım Ne
yapacağım ben diye böyle kendi
bedeninize uğraşmaktan bu sefer sınava
sırada kaçıp gidiyor gibi şimdi üçüncü
belirtiler var duygusal belirtiler
Bunlar Ağlama gerginlik huzursuzluk öfke
politik yaşama aşırı gerginlik
huzursuzluk yaşamam heyecan çok
heyecanlanma Bunlar sabitler şimdi
olumsuz bir düşüncem var benim de bunu
hissettim kalbinin çarptığını daraldı
baygınlık hissi yaşadım
çok korkuyorum endişeliyim Ağlamak
üzereyim ağlıyorum evde bunun
davranışlar belirtileri oluyor bunlar
neler Mesela sınava girmeme sınavı
bırakıp gitme derslerden kaçınma sık Hiç
yerinde duramama sık sık gezinmeye
hareket etme uykunun iştahın bozulması
gibi ve hatta ne yazık ki iPhone sigara
ve uyuşturucu maddelere yönelme gibi
hani olumsuz davranışsal sonuçları
olabiliyor bu Umarım Bunların hepsi
sınav kaygısının bileşenleri Aslında
tabi tedavide neler yapıyoruz Aslı
tedavi bizim için Hedef düşünceyi
değiştirmek oluyor çünkü düşünce Dediğim
gibi benim düşüncem ve Ben düşündüm de
bunun olacağı diye bir şey yok yani bu
sadece ben benim düşüncem Yani kesin
ortaya çıkan bir durum değil düşünce
yönelik çalışıyoruz çünkü düşünce
değiştiği zaman kendimizi
sakinleştirebiliriz eğer uyguladığımızda
sakin diyor kalp atışımız da yavaşlıyor
ya Ondan sonrasında da oldu davranışsal
olarak dışa vuran gerginlik geldiğiniz
için sorunlar da ortadan kaldım kalkıyor
o yüzden düşüncelerimizi a sınırlandırma
mız gerekiyor şimdi ben değilim ki
düşünüyorum diyorum ki ben ben işte
şimdi bu soruya takıldım İşte 25 soruya
takıldım Eyvah yapamayacağım galiba bak
işte burada zamanımı yedim gitti bu
sınav Tamam bitti artık olmaz benden
olmaz artık Osman gitti diye düşündüm bu
benim düşünce aklıma geldiği zaman şöyle
demem lazım bir dur düşünce yani bu Ben
düşündüm diye olacak diye bir şey yok
bana ait bir düşünce Sen düşünce burada
bir dur ben şu an sana odaklanma
yapacağım Çünkü bu olumsuz bir düşünce
Ben bunun farkındayım Benim yapacağım
şey Evet 25. soru zor olabilir a
Ama ben bunu geçeyim o zaman 26 sorudan
devam edeyim 26-27 soru getiriyor zamanı
kalırsa 25 döner bakarım elimden geleni
de yaparım onu da önemli olan benim
elimden geleni yapmam Ya zamanım kalırsa
25. soru yaparım Eğer yapamam Eğer siz
sınav esnasında direkt sonucu
odaklanırsanız o alacağınız mı geçeceğim
sınav baraj puanları odaklanırsanız bu
sıradaki konsantrasyonunuzu
kaybedebilirsiniz ha yaşayacağımız
kaygıdan dolayı yani 25 soru
yapamadığımız zaman Eyvah bitti bu sınav
bak ne olacak artık yine Hani kaybettim
ben dediğimiz zaman nasıl sonucu
odaklanıyoruz Evet sebepte bu aslında
sonucu odaklanma o sesi sınav kaygısını
adım adım ilerlemeniz Ama bu soruyu
yaptım diğerine geçtim yapamadım sonra
bu işte vaktim kalırsa bakarım vaktim
kaldığında yapabilirsem yaparım
yapamazsam yapamam yani sadece ana
odaklanmak gerekiyor evet yazmaya
çalışırken de mesela bazen dikkatiniz
dağılabilir bazen canımız o gün
istemeyebilir Eyvah Ben bugün
çalışamadım herkes çalıştı bak Ben
geride kaldım herkes sınavda geçecek
Yapacak istediği puanı alacak Ben
yapamayacağım şimdi o da aslında çalışma
stratejisi Bir de sınavın sadece geniş
bir alanı gibi düşünmek lazım Evet ben o
gün çalışmamış olabilirim istediğim
şekilde Ancak bu sonrasında
çalışabilirim yani o gün çalışmamış
olmam Benim sadece o anlık Yaşadığım bir
olumsuz durum benim üniversite sınavında
liseye giriş sınavında vermedin atıyorum
ehliyetsınavında yaşayacağım yaşayacağım
sonuca yönelik bir olumsuzluk değil
aslında sonrasında Ben bunu telafi
bu elimden geleni yine gösterebilirim o
an yapamamış olmam çalışmamış olmam Yaş
25 soru yapamamış olmam sınıf yapamamış
olmamız sınavın sonucuna odaklandığım
zaman sadece o an fıtıklı kalkmaktan
geçiyor bu yani oha mı geçiyor sonucu
etkiliyor ilerlemek lazım gibi
düşünmekte düşünceleri değiştirmek ile
ilgili nasıl olumsuzları olumlu Lara
çevirebiliriz ile ilgili Ben Ali öyle
Birkaç örnek yapacağım hani size
soracağım Bu nasıl olumluya
çevirebiliriz diye Çünkü sizin
yaşadığınız Aslında durumlardan
bahsedeceğim biraz o şekilde böyle bir
şey yaparız soru-cevap gibi yaparız
gerekirse fikirlerinizi alalım size o
yüzden aklımda olumsuz düşünce
geldiğiniz zaman bir sınır koymamız
gerekiyor Evet bu benim düşüncem bu bir
olumsuz düşünce Şu an bunu ben
oluşturuyorum benim oluşturduğum bu
oğlum
Az önce ona kesin olacağı anlamına
gelmiyor o yüzden sen bir kenara
çekildim aranızda bir sınıf koymak
gerekiyor düşünceyle bu şekilde kaydı
Biraz yavaşlatmak azaltmak gerekiyor
Evet bu işimize yarayabilir işinize
yarayabilir ancak yaramadı Hala kendi
geldiğini hissediyorsunuz huzursuz
hissediyorsunuz aynı böyle şey
çarpıntılı Devam ediyor eğitimimiz Devam
ediyor ha karnınız gurulduyor nefes
darlığı hissediyorsunuz böyle durumlarda
ve gevşeme egzersizleri var şimdi bazen
bazı kişiler nefes egzersizi ile gevşeme
egzersizi farklı farklı verebilir ama
ben zamanda vermeyi özel ı sınav
esnasında sorun yaşarsınız zaman sarılıp
olarak görüyorum Doğrusu yanlışı Yok
ayrı ayrı da yapılabilir e dediğim gibi
bu süreçte birçok Ekol var bu sınav
kaygısı ile ilgili
değil ile ilgili ama ben ikisini kombine
yapmayı zaman tasarrufu açısından tercih
ediyorum Hani ondan da bahsedeceğim size
şimdi sadece Önümüzdeki üniversite
sınavı baz alarak konuşursam önünüzde
şimdi 6-7 gün kal Altı gün kaldı bunun
arkasında Selam söyleyeceğim ben Sezer
sizin yapabilirsiniz Her gün bir
sabah-akşam yapmak ayrı yaşayan
kişilerin rahatlatacaktır Onun dışında
bir sınavda çok sorun yaşadığınızda
beyaz Türkçe'den matematikten
matematikten sen büyüksün vesaire geçiş
yaparken değer zamanla ilgili bir
sıkıntınız yoksa bir dakika kendimizi bu
şekilde rahatlata bilir siniz çok kaygı
olan durumlarda rahatlatıcı olacaktır
faydası olacak bu sınava girecek olan
kişilerle ilgilide sabah-akşam yapıldığı
zaman yine bu son hastalarla ilgili de
Zaten birkaç öneride bulunacağım Ben
size son
bu sabah akşam yapıldığı zaman sizin
motivasyonunuzu artırır Heyecanın suda
kontrol edebildiğiniz de gayret gösterdi
olacaktır iyi gelecektir diye
düşünüyorum şimdi elinizi göğsünüze bir
elinizi karnınıza koyduğunuz koyun Yani
hepimizin koymalıyız burnunuzdan
Öncelikle nefes alma atacağım bağımsız
sonrasında nasıl kombin ettiğimizi
söyleyeceğim anlatacağız el şöyle
göstereyim Kiel düz değil suyu koyuyorum
değilim diyorsun bebeğim hanım da
süreler değişiklik gösterir üç saniye
diğer var beş saniye diyen var on saniye
diyen var olabildiğince yavaş diyorum
beş saniye al başlar ve ver diyorum
Önemli olan olabildiğince yavaş almak
hissetmek nefesimi burnumdan alıyorum
beş saniyede ama Kargo Ciğerlerimi değil
Karnım şiş
Yok yok yani alt karnımdaki Elim daha
çok kıpır duyacak göğsümdeki Elim daha
az ağırlayacak ve saniye boyunca yavaşça
alıyorum içimden sayıyorum sonra da
yavaşça ağzından ediyorum yine beş
saniye dedi sadece bunu bile on kere
yaptığımız yani 10 10 100 saniye kadar
yapar zaten ya ben arkadaşlarım adına
öğretmenlerin adına Ekim abla çok
teşekkür ediyorum de bize zaman
ayırdığınız için çok güzel çok verimli
bir konuda çok teşekkür ikizleri de
bundan doğum günü kutlamaları ekliyoruz
onların önünde çok yılan bu senin köşe
başlayacaklar başlayacak öğrencilik
Eyvah Eyvah diyorum yani
mi Evet yani ben de çok memnun oldum Çok
teşekkür ederim hepinize tekrar böyle
yüz yüze görüşürüz toplantıyı
tekrarlarız davet edersiniz çağırırsınız
her zaman yanınızdayım çok mutlu gittim
Hadi Ben elimden geldiğince her türlü
sizlere destek olmak istiyorum her zaman
çok teşekkürler Çok bayağı Emeğiniz
geçti konuşma çok önemliydi Kendinize
iyi bakın kapatıyorum yavaş yavaş
görüşmek üzere Herkese